israel announces a ceasefire with hamas
anti-semitic attacks break out in major
american cities and cnn's chris cuomo is
exposed for helping his brother
while covering him for the most trusted
name in news i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first
just be clear about this there are only
a couple of things that are sure things
in life
death taxes and that you're paying too
much for your cell phone bill if you're
using one of the traditional
cell phone coverage providers instead
you need to switch over to pure talk
usa in fact pure talk will save the
average family of four over eight
hundred dollars a year here's the best
part you don't have to sacrifice
coverage because it's
on the exact same network as one of the
big providers switching is super simple
you can keep your phone you can keep
your number or you can get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and i know what you're
thinking well what if i use more
than six gigs of data good news for you
if you go over on the data they are not
going to charge you for it over at pure
talk usa
it's just one of the many reasons
they've been named the top wireless
provider
by consumer affairs so how do you get
started tile
pound 250 on your cell phone and say ben
shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month again dial
pound 250 say my name
ben shapiro you say 50 off your very
first month and hundreds of bucks
down the road there is no reason to pay
too much for that cell phone bill the
cell phone providers that kind of fib to
you about what it is that you need what
you need is what pure talk usa is going
to give you i'll pound 250 say ben
shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month alrighty so
big news over the course of the last 24
hours
israel voted in its security cabinet
that they were going
to announce a ceasefire and hamas then
quickly agreed to a ceasefire
because israel stopped short of
completely destroying hamas this meant
the palestinians were out in the streets
firing fireworks and declaring victory
weird thing to declare victory when your
infrastructure has been
crumbled many of your leadership have
been killed
and it's also very weird to declare
victory when your entire basis for
victory
was supposedly that you stood up to this
massive israeli barrage but you actually
didn't right
that's that's the part that's kind of
weird so you complain the entire time
about how mean israel is
and then israel eviscerates a lot of
your infrastructure and then you declare
victory
the real answer is that the palestinians
under hamas
declared victory because they got what
they wanted from the world media and
what they got from the world media was
this vast turn against israel and it's
an amazing thing
because the media just decided to
conflate hamas and palestinians though
they are the same thing
as though hamas which is the the
governing terrorist group in the gaza
strip and has been since 2006
has a coincident interest with the
palestinians who live under its
misrule who live under the the boot heel
of this terrorist regime
according to the washington post a
ceasefire aimed at ending 11 days of
withering combat between israel and
hamas militants
took effect early on friday hours after
israel's security cabinet voted to
approve
an egyptian initiative to stop the
fighting the cabinet made up of top
security
officials and ministers voted
unanimously to accept what israel
described
as a bilateral and unconditional
ceasefire facing mounting international
pressure including from president biden
in recent days the israeli government
said it decided to bring the air and
artillery campaign to a halt
after significantly degrading hamas's
military infrastructure and killing many
of its commanders
hamas said that it had also agreed with
the egyptian proposal
sahir al-munu a media adviser said the
palestinian resistance will abide by
this agreement as long as the occupation
is committed israel pounded gaza with
airstrikes and artillery fire
causing extensive destruction killing
232 palestinians including at least
65 children now it should be noted that
whenever these death counts they
typically come from the
hamas information ministry and very
often those numbers are wrong and it
turns out later that it
it becomes clear how wrong they were but
any child who died as a result of this
in the gaza strip is a direct result of
hamas which plants weapons and
terrorists behind children
we've played tape on this show of people
in gaza
explicitly saying two israeli forces who
are warning them to get out of buildings
we want to leave our kids here so if you
hit the building then you get blamed
internationally
hamas ferocious rocketing left 12 dead
in israel two of them children sent
residents and much of the country
repeatedly
fleeing for shelter as the hour struck
gaza residents cheered from their
terraces celebratory gunfire sounded
over the mostly dark neighborhoods a few
horns that sounded from cars braving
streets pocket
parked with shell craters and praised
for god rang out from mosques around
gaza city it's it's unbelievable
you fire hundreds of rockets at civilian
areas and then you just
have your infrastructure bombed into
next week
and your reaction to a ceasefire is
we won now there was no such reaction in
israel
the reason there was no such reaction in
israel because israel doesn't want the
conflict
and this is one of the things that i was
noting a few days ago about
videos of rockets being fired from gaza
what you saw is people
in the streets actively celebrating when
rockets were fired into gaza you didn't
see any of that in israel didn't see
anybody
in in israeli society cheering as the
f-22s took off
on their bombing runs but you did see
that in the gaza strip
there's a vast moral imbalance between
israel and its enemies in this
particular war
for his part joe biden praised benjamin
netanyahu for abiding by the ceasefire
and agreeing to the ceasefire here was
president biden
in my conversation with president
netanyahu i commended him
for the decision to bring the current
hostilities to a close within
less than 11 days i also emphasize what
i've said
throughout this conflict the united
states fully supports israel's right to
defend itself
against indiscriminate rocket attacks
from hamas
and other gaza-based terrorist groups
that have taken the lives of innocent
civilians
in israel now there's something that joe
biden did not mention in his speech and
that of course is the vast wave of
anti-semitic attacks that's now hitting
american cities
it's european cities as well there's a
increase in anti-semitic incidents in
the uk in the middle of the gaza war
this has happened
during many of the conflicts that have
happened in the middle east
very often people who say well it's just
anti-scientific just anti-zionism it's
just anti-israel activity it's not about
the jews
we're why are you attacking that random
jew in london very very strange
and same people who say well if israel
went away there would be less
anti-semitism meanwhile beating a jew
like
good good good idea guys like really
that makes a whole hell of a lot of
sense
biden didn't mention this because the
left has a perverse perspective on
anti-semitism which is that
anti-semitism
only matters when the person committing
the anti-semitism is a white supremacist
when it turns out that anti-semitism is
a mainstream part of an increasingly
mainstream segment
of the international left then
anti-semitism has to be ignored in other
words when anti-semitism is part of a
political program a broader political
program
to for example end the jewish state or
part of a broader political program
to set up jews who are
disproportionately well-educated and
successful in western societies
as sort of the evil at the top of the
intersectional hierarchy
as beneficiaries of a system that needs
to be brought down then anti-semitism
gets ignored which of course is why the
democratic party
just last year decided that they were
not going to bother censoring
uh or censuring rather ilhan omar for
her blatant anti-semitism
instead they decided that they were
going to pass some sort of broad
resolution condemning all bad things on
planet earth
because the reality is that the left
cannot acknowledge anti-semitism when it
comes
from the left instead they have to
pretend that it just doesn't exist
and so as we'll see there have been a
bevy of anti-semitic attacks in the
united states
over the course of the last week it is
not a coincidence that it is happening
in the middle of this conflict with
israel because the same peop
again these people are siding with hamas
okay hamas is a terrorist group
this is not about a border conflict
hamas openly states it wants israel
completely destroyed which means a
genocide of the jews
today the front page of the new york
times website has zero
articles about the uptick in
anti-semitic crime the washington post
its front page today online has zero
stories
about anti-semitism across the nation
both ran
op-eds talking about why it would be
necessary for israel to stop existing
that is not a coincidence anti-semitism
is part and parcel of the broader
international left agenda at this point
and that agenda is to tear down any
vestiges
and systems that they believe are are
implicit in the west and israel is just
part of that right the the international
left hates israel because they really
don't like the the
traditional systems of the west not the
other way around
in just one second we'll get to the
anti-semitic attacks that have been
happening
in new york we already saw that
happening in los angeles we'll get to
that in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact and that
is that if you're a responsible person
you need life insurance you need to make
sure that your family is taken care of
in case god forbid something should
happen to you
policy genius makes it super simple to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place
why compare well you can save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius
it could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google
getting started is super simple first
you head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you are ready to
apply
the policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies policy
genius doesn't add on extra fees head on
over to policygenius.com to get started
right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and super important to get it
right get the life insurance
that you need at policygenius.com
shapiro
right now okay so before we get into
these anti-semitic incidents
a quick primer on when anti-semitism is
coincident
with anti-israel sentiment hey so you
can disagree with israeli policy
i often disagree with israeli policy i
for example
think that israel never should have
pulled out of the gaza strip in 2005.
i think handing it over to hamas was a
terrible decision i think israel never
should have engaged in the oslo process
with a terrorist group known as the
palestine liberation organization
and that doesn't make me anti-semitic
and people on the other side who believe
that israel should make more concessions
that doesn't doesn't mean that you are
anti-semitic there are a few key
indicators as to when
anti-israel sentiment bleeds over into
anti-semitism one if you're siding with
an active terrorist group that is firing
indiscriminately rockets at civilians
while shielding its own weaponry with
children it's very hard to come up with
an alternative explanation for why you
think that is okay other than you don't
like jews
if you are treating the jewish state in
a way you would treat no other state if
there's a double standard okay and this
isn't my standard is the state
department standard for anti-semitism
if you treat the jewish state in a way
different then you would treat any other
state
it's an indicator of anti-semitism okay
so those are a couple indicators of when
anti-israel sentiment bleeds over
into anti-semitism and by the way if you
wish to see the full-scale destruction
of the state of israel
you don't wish to see the destruction of
any other state on planet earth right
you don't wish to see the destruction
of any islamic regime there are over 50
50 of them like 57 57-58 members
of the organization of islamic countries
explicitly islamic
full-on apartheid states for people of
other religions you don't care about
that
you don't care about the 100 plus
countries that are christian in
orientation
all you care about is the one jewish
state that looks an awful lot like an
anti-semitic double standard
and well the left has embraced that
because the left sees israel as a
repository of colonialism in the region
which has to ignore
all of human history there have been
jews in this region since 1000 bce
jewish presence in the holy land
predates the existence of islam by some
600 years minimum
the first and second temples were built
hundreds of years
before islam even existed and so the
notion that this is some sort of
colonialist outpost of western
civilization
is a particularly bizarre one
considering how jews were often treated
throughout europe
and throughout russia and throughout
every other place throughout human
history
the notion that the jews were sort of
like put there by the europeans in order
to bother the arabs is insane especially
considering the fact
that british mandate palestine attempted
explicitly to bar jews from buying land
for decades on end
and restricted jewish immigration that
in in a way that had never restricted
arab immigration including restricting
jewish immigration from europe
during world war ii as jews were being
sent to the gas chambers in europe
and post-world war ii in order to
placate the local arab population
and so you have to just ignore all of
history to come to the conclusion that
this is a colonialist settler outpost
but that is exactly what the left wants
to say because this all fits into a
broader left-wing
world view the broader left-wing
worldview is that anyone who is
successful
in a western system is successful
because they have somehow victimized the
other
it's the same thing that you see in
america with regards to critical race
theory that
inequality of outcome is evidence of
discrimination same thing when it comes
to global politics if israel is very
successful and the palestinians are not
particularly successful that is not
because the palestinian leadership
are a bunch of terrorists who have
misdirected all funding
toward terrorism and destroyed property
rights and made it
impossible for people to start
businesses and crack down on dissent
and have destroyed democracy and
actually live in a one-party apartheid
state
now it's not because of any of that it
must be because there's this other group
that's very successful right next to
them
despite the fact that that other group
20 of its population is arab they're
arabs who sit in the knesset it's a very
large part of the iran party
they're arabs who sit on the supreme
court all of this is perfectly obvious
so if you ignore all of that just
because you don't like israel at that
point you have to start looking
at the possibility that anti-semitism
lies behind this okay and
again that is why it is no coincidence
that you're seeing palestinian
anti-semitism on the streets of the
united states
and you're seeing people on the left
look the other way this is not being
covered in the mainstream media in much
the same way
that the mainstream media really didn't
want to cover anti-asian violence in the
united states
until there was that mass shooting by
somebody that could label the white
supremacist in atlanta
right when that happened then they could
talk about anti-asian violence and they
could pass an anti-asian hate crime bill
but they will not pass an anti-semitic
hate crime
crackdown bill they certainly won't do
that because the people who are largely
promulgating anti-semitism in the united
states these days are on the political
left and that is being mainstreamed into
the political left
so here are some videos these are from
new york over the last 48 hours
by the way palestinian protesters are
specifically
attempting to set up protests in jewish
areas all around the country
the reason they're doing that of course
is because they believe that these are
pro-israel centers
and so they have to get in the face of
every jew in order to in order to
demonstrate
something i'm not sure what it is they
think they're demonstrating
okay this one was really bad yesterday
there were some some
i mean this this is an act of terrorism
i mean somebody went and took a small
molotov cocktail
and they took it down to the diamond
district in new york
and they they threw like an actual
explosive in the diamond district okay
then
they went to a restaurant these
palestinian activists and by
activism criminals they went to because
there are activists and there are
criminals if you go to a
if you go to a restaurant you start
spitting on people you start spitting on
jewish niners
you're a criminal assault you have
palestinian activists
who are riding down the street shouting
f the jews
it's good times in uh good times in new
york over there
uh there is a a full-on brawl that broke
out when palestinian activists decided
they were going to attack
uh jewish activists there were jewish
activists holding israeli flags
palestinian activists went and grabbed
the flag away from them
and then started to uh beat up the jews
uh there are a couple of uh this is in
times square so this is just
wonderful stuff by the way where are the
cops in all this
like seriously where where are the
police and we've seen this in los
angeles
we saw in los angeles that there were
jews who were eating outside of the
sushi restaurant on los angeles
boulevard
and palestinian activists slash
criminals
decided that they were going to stop try
to shout at the jews get out of their
car and then go and beat up the jews we
saw a jew being chased down by a couple
of of trucks with giant palestinian
flags on the back
all this stuff is happening and the
media just have no interest
in covering the actual crimes you'll see
an occasional story about eric garcetti
in l.a for example condemning the hate
crimes
nothing yet from bill de blasio so far
as i'm aware nothing from andrew cuomo
the governor of new york
nothing from chuck schumer the jewish
senator from new york
nothing in fact from anybody in the
democratic party hierarchy
why the answer is because if they
recognize
that perhaps the people who are siding
with hamas very often are driven
well not very often if you side with
hamas not just you don't like some
things israel's doing you side with
hamas
this means you're an anti-semite there's
just no way to read you siding with an
actual overt evil terrorist group
as anything other than you hate the
people that the terrorists are
attempting to kill
okay and and this has mainstreamed
itself into
the into media so there's open
anti-semitism
and it exists largely at the highest
echelons of the islamic world
and particularly in islamically governed
countries like pakistan
there was a pakistani foreign minister
who just went on cnn and frankly good
for the cnn host here the cnn host
called him on it but the pakistani
foreign minister literally won a
national television and said the jews
run the media
which is which is pretty wild we'll get
to that in just one second but msnbc is
busily actually promulgating the
anti-semitism
just like members of the democratic
party are promulgating the anti-semitism
just like the washington post is
promulgating the anti-semitism now
this doesn't mean that everybody in the
democratic party higher echelon
is an anti-semite it just means they're
winking and nodding at it
i mean joe biden any time could say
something about ilhan omar and rashida
talib instead
joe biden who was fairly tolerant of
israel
performing its duty to defend its
citizens he was out there praising
rashida to leave well where should
he was being an open anti-semite
supporting actual act of terrorism
okay in just one second we are going to
get to more of this
first let's talk about the fact that big
tech
would love to cancel your right to free
speech or at the very least restrict it
and then they make money off of you the
way that they do this is they gather all
the data they can about you and then
they sell that to third parties
they track your searches your video
history everything you click on and then
they sell your valuable data to third
parties and when you use expressvpn
you can stop all of this your device's
ip address gets masked this helps
anonymize your online activity making it
much more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
network data to protect you from cyber
criminals and hackers
but i love most about expressvpn it does
all of these things with just one tap of
a button it could not be simpler to use
you just fire up the app on any of your
devices you hit connect
and now you are protected it's time to
say no to censorship and take back your
online privacy at expressvpn.com
ben visit my link you'll get an extra
three months of expressive vpn service
for free
that's expressvpn.com to protect your
data today
expr essvpn.com to protect
your data today again you don't want to
give bigtech the keys to the car
instead protect your data the way that i
do use expressvpn.com
when you visit that link you get an
extra three months of express vpn
service
for free alrighty so the the
anti-semitism
that exists all over the world is now
being mainstreamed by for example msnbc
so we'll get to actually cnn doing the
right thing here as a change i mean this
is really kind of a shocking change
the pakistani foreign minister was on
cnn and just started spewing
random anti-semitic nonsense but as you
will see the position that this guy
takes is actually a fairly commonly held
position on the
on the american left unfortunately
israel
is losing out they're losing the media
war despite their connections
they are losing the media war the tide
is done
deep pockets what does that mean
well they're very influential people i
mean they control media
i mean i i would call that an
anti-semitic remark
well you see the point is uh they
have a lot of influence meowing
actually doing what an anchor there is
supposed to do that is the foreign
minister of pakistan okay it's a
high-ranking official
in a foreign government talking about
how the jews control the media
okay now this sort of stuff
unfortunately is
fairly well spoken of
in elite liberal circles i mean the fact
is that this has been a
commonly held and pervasive myth on the
left for a very long time
including by people who actually serve
inside the biden administration
robert malloy used to make comments like
this about how the american media
was controlled by the israeli lobby and
all the rest of this okay but msnbc
actually just mainstreams this so
what you've seen there are two articles
in the last two days one in the new york
times and one in the washington post
explicitly talking
about how the two-state solution was
done now why is the two-state solution
done
according to them the two-state solution
is done not because terrorist groups run
the west bank and run the gaza strip
and have explicitly refused to
acknowledge the the
right of the state of israel to exist no
it's not because of that
it's because what you really need is a
one is a one
state solution between the jordan river
and the mediterranean sea
whereby arabs swamp the jewish
population and they turn it into another
islamic state
there's an actual article in the
washington post today about this by sean
theroux
suggesting that this is the wave of the
future there's another article in the
washington post
talking up rashida talib the open
anti-semite it's an it's a it's a piece
by michael crash titled
eight minutes with the president
representative rashida talib the lone
palestinian american in congress
gains relevance in israel debate well
she's getting relevance because you guys
keep giving her relevance
and because the democratic party refuses
to quash its own anti-semitism
elena omar is not shy about her
anti-semitism or she told he's not try
better anti-semitism and alexander
ocasio-cortez
when you back hamas and when you attack
israel is an apartheid state at the same
time that you are supporting a one-party
terror state in the gaza strip
and when you hang out with rashida talib
and no hanamar and back all of their
plays when you attempt to block military
aid
to an american ally in a time when
they're under consistent rocket fire
when you hang out with jeremy corbyn i'm
not going to sugarcoat this
you are now in the anti-semitic category
you have now exited
the point where you are where you are
just in ignoramus and you have entered
the anti-semitic category which is true
of alexander
ocasio-cortez it's true of corey bush
it's true of the squad the squad has
decided to engage full scale in
anti-semitism
by the state department definition
treating israel with a double standard
demonizing israel
treating jews as extensions of israel
and this
all of this sort of stuff is stuff that
is routinely done by the squad
and the media as well right msnbc
hosted the sponsor of boycott divestment
and sanctions yesterday
okay that's that's omar barghouti omar
goodi's like an open anti-semite
very he has explicitly stated that
boycott divested sanctions of israel
which is an attempt to get everybody to
stop doing business with the state of
israel he's explicitly said that his
goal is the destruction of the state of
israel here he was being touted on msnbc
yesterday
the united states government is
complicit through its military funding
academic institutions cultural
institutions funds uh
investment funds are are also complicit
when they invest in companies
that are enabling the occupation the
house demolition and so on so we're
calling for ending complicity
so that palestinians can achieve our
rights under international law and
nothing beyond that and enter the
occupation into apartheid and the rights
of refugees
okay okay when he says the rights of
refugees what he means is that
every palestinian should be allowed into
israel to be a citizen of israel
despite the fact that they explicitly
say they want to destroy the state of
israel this is the equivalent
of during the cold war the united st the
left in the united states saying we
should give citizenship to every member
of the international communist party
in order to come to the united states so
they can vote to get rid of the united
states everybody understands this there
has never been in human history a quote
unquote right of return
to a foreign state that is not a thing
without the permission of the state
involved that is
that has never been a thing in any case
the the bds co-founder then went on and
called israel an apartheid state and
praised aoc in the process
okay and and this guy's been not shy
about what his actual goals are i'll
play his goals in a second omar
barghouti
they realize israel is an apartheid
state that was an absolute taboo just a
year ago
today how many members of congress are
saying israel is an apartheid state how
many members of congress are calling for
conditioning aid to israel or cutting
military funding to israel altogether
corey bush for example congresswoman
corey bush connected
a palestinian liberation with the black
lives matter movement
saying that let's not send any military
funding to an apartheid regime
we must be anti-apartheid period she
said aoc
said apartheid is no democracy so those
voices are rising
okay those he's right those voices are
rising incomplicit
in complicity with actual anti-semites
like omar bagudi he has explicitly said
that his entire movement is designed to
destroying the state of israel
and destroying the jewish state this is
the last year this is may of last year
he's gonna be speaking in arabic and
i'll redo the translation
if the refugees return to their homes in
israel as the bds movement calls for
what will be left of the zionist regime
there won't be any zionist state like
the one we are talking about present-day
israel
and the palestinian minority will become
a palestinian majority in the state that
today is called israel
because he's openly like he openly
acknowledges what his goals are
and everyone knows this and msnbc is
pushing it and aoc is pushing it and
omar is pushing it and rashida talib is
pushing it and the washington post is
pushing it
and where is the higher echelon of the
democratic party if you think this is
unrelated to tolerance or anti-semitic
incidents on the streets of new york
you're out of your mind
of course it is of course it is the
tolerance for anti-semitic incidents is
tied to the fact that the people who are
participating in the anti-semitism
are supporters of some of the biggest
democrats in congress
they're people who ideologically hold
the same positions as democrats in
congress in the same way
that for a year and a half democrat
democrats decided they would completely
overlook
and or cheer on rioting and looting
because those people
agreed with them on fundamental
principles and sure they might go a
little bit too far
and they might not love it but let's
acknowledge that they have a point
this is the same reason why they're
completely ignoring the anti-semitic
attacks that are happening
in new york i mean bernie sanders who is
when people say that bernie sanders is a
jew he is ethnically jewish and he has
no relationship with judaism
none okay he is he is not a jew by
culture he is not a jew by belief
he is not a jew in any sense other than
ethnic judaism
in the same way that if you are born
into a catholic family perhaps you are
ethnically catholic if that were if that
were a thing and then if you don't
practice catholicism in fact you spend
all your life attempting to rip down
catholicism it'd be very difficult to
call you a catholic
same sort of thing with bernie sanders
he's not a religious jew he is not a
political
like he is not oriented toward judaism
or or toward the state of israel in any
political way
which is the democratic party uses him
as cover the radical democrats use him
as cover he's been radically anti-israel
his entire career
so he and aoc moved to block a private
weapons sale to israel in the middle of
all of this
that of course is no shock the the house
democrats
just voted down yesterday a re-armament
an ability to re-arm
the iron dome which is a purely
defensive technology yesterday house
democrats
voted 218 to 209 to reject a security
funding amendment
offered by representative tony gonzalez
of texas the measure would have paved
the way for israel to receive a tranche
of emergency dollars
specifically for missile defense if the
democrats voted that down so don't
pretend that the democratic party isn't
complicit
in the in the anti-israel move i good
for joe biden for holding out
as long as he did against these folks
but when is he going to speak up
against the anti-semitism inside his own
party rashida talib is busily tweeting
if my colleagues even mention
palestinians deserving human rights they
are aggressively bullied
by those who prefer israel as it is
apartheid oppression occupation and all
my message to you is all of this to you
all is this do not be afraid to stand
for justice
the american people are with us the
american people are absolutely not with
you by any pole statistic
but the democrats are too afraid of
people like rashida talib because she is
intersectional
she then quotes peter beinart who is
hamas favorite commentator
and who also believes that israel should
essentially be destroyed he says the
reason the american debate over israel
palestine could shift dramatically and
quickly
is that many democratic politicians
don't need to be convinced that what
israel is doing is wrong
they just need to be convinced that they
can say so without hurting their careers
i don't think that binary is completely
wrong about this i think the binary
recognizes that the democratic party has
moved in a radically anti-israel
direction
the same way that peter beinart has
moved in a radically anti-israel
direction
and that has consequences i'm old enough
to remember when democrats suggested
that anti-semitic attacks against jews
were driven by trump's
unmore rhetoric with regard to white
supremacy or something they blame the
tree of life shooting
on donald trump they get a wide spate of
anti-semitic attacks it has nothing to
do
with the democrats in new york
explicitly talking about the evils of
israel how it's an apartheid state
and how israel does not have the duty to
defend itself and siding with an actual
terrorist group
you have the democratic party at the
highest echelons refusing to condemn
the anti-semites in their own ranks and
it has no impact at all
you're gonna have to explain that one
and bottom line is anti-semitism from
left is fine according to the left end
of story
it is completely fine and they'll just
push
full-on anti-semitism in the media
including up to and including
full-on pieces calling for the
destruction of the state of israel when
people say one state solution understand
what they are calling for is the
destruction of the state of israel in
the way that they are articulating this
and you have top democrats of course
trying to actually block israel from
being able to defend its own citizens
remember every anti-missile missile that
is fired by the iron dome costs about a
hundred thousand dollars these are smart
weapons
every rocket that is fired by hamas
costs less than a thousand dollars they
are very cheap to put together they are
dummy weapons that are being
just sent in randomly to kill as many
civilians as possible
so it's much more expensive to arm iron
dome than it is to build a dummy rocket
and yet in the middle of this the
democrats are trying to cut funding it's
pretty incredible it's pretty incredible
okay in just one second
we are going to get to cnn blowing out
its own credibility once more
first let us talk about your sleep
quality let's talk about the fact that
for me i've got my kids waking me up at
all hours when i am on my mattress i
need to be sleeping i can't be tossing
and turning i can't be uncomfortable i
need a mattress made just for me and
helix sleep made that happen
just for me my wife and i took their two
minutes sleep quiz they sent us a
mattress that is personalized
for us everybody is unique helix sleep
knows that they have several different
mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz they send you the mattress
and then you just unbox it and inflates
right in front of it you pop it on the
bed frame you are good to go
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gqn wired magazine just
head on over to helixsleep.com
ben take their two minutes sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life they've got a 10-year
warranty
you have to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.comixsleep.com
ben 200 bucks off all mattress orders
and two free pillows helix sleep.com
ben alrighty meanwhile cnn just
disgraced itself once again according to
the washington post chris cuomo
took part in strategy calls advising his
brother this is not a shock in any way
shape or form
i mean it's pretty obvious this is going
to happen the only thing that's
humiliating about this for cnn is that
chris cuomo got caught
and the fact is that jeff zucker was on
the phone with like donald trump during
the 2016 campaign
members of the media are constantly
strategizing with other members of the
democratic party because the media is an
entirely democratic-run operation at
this point
there's a reason why ap and hamas are
are in the same building
ap does propaganda work for hamas in the
gaza strip
the the notion that the media does not
have very cozy relationships with the
people that it covers is just insane
which of course is why the entire media
is out in defense of chris cuomo today
despite the fact it should be a pretty
humiliating headline according to the
washington post
cnn anchor chris cuomo advised his
brother new york governor andrew cuomo
and senior members of the governor's
staff on how to respond to sexual
harassment allegations made earlier this
year
by women who had worked with the
governor according to four people
familiar with the discussions
cuomo one of the network's top stars
joined a series of conference calls that
included the democratic governor his top
eight his communications team
lawyers and a number of outside advisors
according to people familiar
with the conversations the cable news
anchor encouraged his brother to take a
defiant position and not to resign
at one point he used the phrase cancel
culture as a reason to hold firm in the
face of the allegations
in a statement cnn acknowledged that
chris cuomo took part in the strategy
sessions saying his involvement was a
mistake he said chris has not been
involved in cnn's extensive coverage of
the allegations against governor cuomo
on air or behind the scenes in part
because as he has said on the show he
could never be objective but also
because he often serves as a sounding
board
for his brother well weird because he
covered him for a year on covid
well he was covering up nursing home
deaths while he was lying to the public
he was covering his own brother on the
air for a year
the statement says it was inappropriate
to engage in conversations that included
members of the governor's staff
which chris acknowledges he will not
participate in such conversations
going forward the anchor said he was
walled off from coverage of the governor
without mentioning the special
dispensation
he received from cnn to feature him on
his show during the pandemic
the episode illuminates how the cuomo
brothers who are 13 years apart at age
have benefited from their respective
high purchase in politics and media
shocker early in the coveted pandemic a
top department of health doctor was
dispatched to the hamptons to test chris
cuomo and his family the washington post
had previously reported
former and current administration
officials said the anchor played an
active role early in the governor's
coronavirus strategy
because he was strategizing with cuomo
on kovid and then covering him on cnn
this is not a shock the brothers
sometimes fish together in the waters
off long island okay
i i can't avoid he's not fredo guys he's
not freighter remember if you say
that chris cuomo is the dumber younger
brother he's smart
not like everyone says not like dumb
like smart and he wants respect
he's not fredo cause apparently
according to chris cuomo if you say that
he is like
fredo like the stupider younger brother
who's being dragged around based on the
family name
if you say that then obviously that is
like he said that was like the n word
for some reason which is weird because
the godfather is like
about an italian crime family and um
i really don't think that the ethnicity
of the cuomo's has much to do with the
fredo reference
it's one of the most iconic references
to a dumb younger brother a dumb older
brother actually in the history of
cinema
but in any case the the governor only
trusts about five people one advisor
with knowledge of the strategy session
said so that's why chris
is on these calls oh inside cnn on
thursday several employees described a
sense of unease about the role cuomo
played in advising his brother
with one calling his decision to do so
really upsetting well i mean if you're
upset
another person said that in a political
climate in which cnn journalists come
under intense scrutiny
having one of their own offering advice
to a major democratic figure felt like a
self-inflicted wound
this one yes it is we were saying this
the entire time
you had him on national tv joking about
does mom love you best
doing smothers brother's routine he's
got a giant q-tip because he got a big
nose
hey now just a couple of flashbacks here
so first of all cuomo has now apologized
and so he went on air last night he
apologized for this uh-huh
i believe him i can be objective about
just about any topic but not about my
family
those of you who watch this show get it
like you i bet
my family means everything to me
and i am fiercely loyal to them
i'm family first job
second i understand why that was a
problem for cnn
it will not happen again it was a
mistake
because i put my colleagues here who i
believe are the best
in the business and a bad spot i never
intended
for that i would never intend for that
and i am sorry
for that okay so here's the thing it's
the most obvious conflict of interest in
media history right i mean his
own brother he's advising him on kovid
and then he's covering him on air
doing joking routines about how he's the
best governor in america and how there
are
homosexuals and and such right you
remember this
okay it was perfectly obvious this was a
conflict why did it never occur to chris
cuomo that it was a conflict
why did it never occur to the cnn
higher-ups this was inappropriate and
the answer is because they all have the
same relationship with the democrats
that chris has with his brother
that's the answer these people have the
same relationship with the biden
administration and had with the obama
team as chris has with his brother
when it comes to the media blood is only
slightly thicker than the water that
passes between
the the media and their democratic
sponsors okay the reality is that the
anchors
on cnn are constantly advising people in
the democratic hierarchy about what they
think they should do
now listen i'm a politically biased
observer i talk with republicans
i advise some republicans i'll tell you
when i've talked with a republican
advisor republican
but you know my political bona fide he's
out front i am not hiding them the
difference is that cnn pretends it's
objective
cnn pretends that they are not lying to
you cnn pretends that they are not
biased in any way that they are somehow
a higher level of news
they're only embarrassed they got caught
and they did get caught
right flashback to chris cuomo not all
that long ago saying yeah it's kind of
unusual that i cover my brother but it's
just something we have to do
me having you on the show is an unusual
thing we've never really done it
uh but this was an unusual time and
there were unusual needs
and you stepped up in an unusual way
that really was
created by a vacuum of power on the
federal level you're not the only one
there are other governors you've been
very good and collaborative with
hogan down in maryland and whitmer and
dewine and the ones up in the northeast
region
um but these unusual times have uh
demonstrated
some unusual characteristics in people
i'm sorry
so he was openly admitting the conflict
of interest way back when
but then as soon as it was sexual
harassment he's like oh well i can't
cover it he's my brother
we all noted the idiocy of this at the
time
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother now of course
cnn has to cover it they have covered it
extensively
and they will continue to do so
i have always cared very deeply
about these issues and profoundly so
i just wanted to tell you that there's a
lot of news going on that matters
also so let's get after
that okay this is
it's ridiculous but it is cnn in a
nutshell this is cnn
this is cnn an apple is an apple a
banana is a banana
and these reporters cover people that
they love and advise on a regular basis
and chris cuomo just got caught that's
all but we was in plain sight there was
nothing to catch
okay in just one second we'll get to the
continued cozy relationship
between the media and the democrats who
are basically their sponsors
they're just their clients we'll get to
that in one second first let us talk
about the fact
that if you are going to make your
business better one tool that you may be
leaving on the table
is the tool of texting podium is a
messaging platform to power your
business it helps you reach your
customers wherever they are
business messaging with podium helps you
gain reviews collect payments
communicate with customers and capture
leads
all from a single inbox podium will help
you adapt to the changing customer
expectations
when i find out a business can text i'm
going to use that business it's more
convenient for me
if i get a cold call i am never ever
going to respond to the cold call if i
get an email it's rare that i will
respond if i get a text
from business telling me about an
appointment telling me about a deal
much better chance that i'm actually
going to take a look at the text this is
why
podium makes your business more
successful rpm alamo increased business
by 20 the owner of rpm almost said we've
generated more revenue
decreased vacancy rates pulled in more
leads than we could have in multiple
years this is priceless
find out how podium can help your
business reach more customers it is a
growth period or should be in the
american economy now is a great time
to get your marketing straight with
podium get started free today at
podium.com
shapiro that is podium.com shapiro and
get in on the texting
revolution all right we're going to get
to more of the media's
pathetic coziness
with the democrats they cover first if
you've noticed that the list of words
you're allowed to say you're shrinking
that's because the list is shrinking and
that is not a good thing which is why
michael moles has a new book
it's called speechless controlling words
controlling minds this book actually has
words in it which i'm very impressed
that knowles actually wrote words
in his book and actually i've read the
book and it's really good head on over
to speechlessbook.com
to pre-order your copy today or if you
want an extra personal touch
text speechless25345 and pre-order a
signed copy don't wait pre-order your
copy today understand the pc police
better than they understand
themselves this sunday we also have a
new episode of the sunday special
i've got a very interesting guest david
horowitz he began his journey into
politics as a self-identified marxist
he will be sitting across from me now as
a conservative activist and founder of
the david horowitz freedom center full
disclosure i used to work
for david over at the freedom center
it's a really interesting interview
it's uh it goes all the way back into
time why he was on the left what he saw
on the left and how the left has become
so successful here's a sneak peek
the left is very intimidating they've
got 61 percent of democrats believing
that all republicans are racists
that's and as i say republicans are
firing back by calling them liberals
or saying they're playing with politics
they're not playing people
[Music]
so check it out this sunday
dailywire.com or on my youtube channel
and shapiro daily where members get
access to special bonus content from
sunday special episodes so don't miss
out
join daily wire today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
hey the cozy relationship between chris
cuomo and his brother andrew
is no different it's just a difference
of degree not a difference of kind
between how the media normally
treat the democratic party there are
dozens and dozens and dozens of members
of the media who immediately jumped
right back into the biden administration
after having been in the obama
administration been hired by cnn then go
right back into the biden administration
you think they didn't talk
with members of the democratic party all
that time
i mean cnn global affairs analyst
anthony blinken is now the secretary of
state
barbara barbara mcquade was an msnbc
columnist
nbc news and msnbc legal analyst and
then was tapped for joe biden's legal
review team
richard stengel was an msnbc political
analyst that used him as a foreign
affairs
reporter richard stengel rather is the
biden harris transition team's lead
official for the u.s agency for global
media
there's so many members of the media who
have been
tapped as possibilities for the biden
administration
in fact you know the reality is that the
media
are just an extension of the democratic
party which is part of the problem
there's a poll out today
and it shows that a huge number of
americans do not
trust the media and my answer is who
does at this point
why would you what exactly are the
statistics that would that would lead
you to believe
that the media are trustworthy they
simply are not
and yet we are told every day that the
people who are the most trustworthy are
members of the establishment media
by the way is chris cuomo going to lose
his job now chris cuomo is going to lose
anything
in fact as even the washington post
notes there is
literally nothing facing chris cuomo at
this point
says eric wemple writing for the
washington post
the cnn issued a statement defending
cuomo quote the early months of the
pandemic crisis
were an extraordinary time we felt that
chris speaking with his brother about
the challenges what millions of american
families were struggling with was a
significant human interest
as a result we made an exception to a
rule we've had in place since 2013
which prevents chris from interviewing
and covering his brother and that rule
remains in place
today according to eric wempel
the reason chris cuomo now acknowledges
it was inappropriate to advise his
brother in strategy sessions is because
he got caught
he gets no credit for acknowledging his
transgression how are we to trust the
pledge not to backslide
and that of course is exactly correct
okay so you wonder why we can't have a
common set of facts
the reason is because very often the
facts are just not reported you can't
have a common set of facts when people
on one side refuse to acknowledge that
the facts even exist
we cover on this show all the time facts
that do not tend
to support republicans and do not help
republicans we covered extensively
january 6th and the lead-up to january
6. we covered extensively
the allegations of voter fraud and voter
irregularities and i said over and over
that i wasn't seeing the evidence
that was being suggested by the trump
campaign
we cover we cover news that that cuts in
all directions and then we comment on
that news
but there are two types of media bias
one is how you cover the news and the
other is what you don't cover
and the fact is the media have just
decided that they don't wish to cover
news they don't wish to cover
which is why you don't see any headlines
over the new york times or washington
post on an uptick in anti-semitic
incidents
it's why you don't see the new york
times or washington post cover
anti-asian hate
until it turns out there's an actual
anti yeah supposedly
targeted anti-asian violent statutory
supposedly because it's not racially
motivated so far as we aware based on
the evidence
but this anti-asian attack in atlanta
no comment on the amount of anti-asian
hate implicit in democratic policy with
regard to for example
campus issues and barring asians from
higher education
the media just ignores stuff
why well because the media and the
democratic party are one in the same
the secret is that is not chris cuomo is
not fredo that chris cuomo is not the
dominant older brother
who who just wants respect the entire
media
alfredo the entire media are are members
of the political establishment who are
jealous
of their elected brothers and wish to be
of aid to them sometimes
and wish to make a buck off of the of
the family name
chris cuomo is just the entire media
writ small
that's all and once you recognize this
you can recognize the agenda in pretty
much everything they do
and you shouldn't take them seriously
and if you do take them seriously at the
very least you ought to get some
countervailing points of view i'll just
note that cnn was rated by the
pathetically stupid organization
newsguard which is supposed to
be the guardian of objective journalism
they're writing eight out of ten in
terms of objectivity
daily in terms of trustworthiness daily
wear was rated a three
that's not because cnn is more
trustworthy it's because cnn is less
trustworthy it's because cnn lies about
what they are
just like the establishment media lie
about what they are on a regular basis
we will tell you the truth about what we
are
and then you get to make up your mind
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com this evening at 7
pm eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover
and our assistant director is pavo
wiedowsky editing is by adam scievents
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin